All right.
Jennifer Kenny, thank you
for being on my show,
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Very well. Delighted to join in.
Thank you.
Where are you calling from right now?
I'm calling from Marin County,
just north of San Francisco.
Oh, wonderful.
Beautiful, beautiful area.
Jennifer, I'm extremely excited
for this talk
because there's gonna be a lot
we're gonna have to talk about
because you have so much experience
in the realm of innovation and leadership
and balanced leadership,
which we'll get to as well,
and really the role of innovation
within organizations.
I'd love to start out with your journey
and who is Jennifer,
and how did you get
to where you are today?
So, I'm actually
a geotechnical engineer by training.
So, I started off
doing geology and chemistry,
but that is the essence
of systems thinking.
So, anyone out there who is a geologist
they know they're one of the best
systems thinkers on the planet
because we understand
the planetary nature of systems thinking.
And then I ended up doing work
in technology
because I wasn't, as a woman, wasn't allowed
to do the work I wanted to do in geology.
And so, I joined
Andersen Consulting in London
and that began my career in technology.
They effectively gave me the equivalent
of a computer science degree,
which was fantastic.
And I have been in technology
and information technology since
most recently as CIO
down at Stanford Research Institute
and now more recently
very, very focused on the whole
research and innovation space.
So, research and innovation space,
what does that even mean?
What does that even entail?
Yeah. So, what that entails
is working directly with people
who are doing robotics,
autonomous driving,
artificial intelligence, block chain,
all of that kind of work
in their research capacity.
So, really helping teams of people
do their optimal to build
the emerging technologies
that are gonna be super exciting
for the future.
And we're beginning to see
some of that already.
So, what is your expertise in that realm?
So, you mentioned
a bunch of different industries.
They're very, very different
from each other
and each require different expertise.
What do you see yourself
as the added value that you bring
when you're examining
these different companies
and you're working with these leaderships?
Yeah. So, my specific expertise
is in what I refer to as human innovation.
Human innovation.
... yeah. So, I ended up doing this work
primarily because
working in information technology,
I always saw that there was a huge missing
in people's ability to be able to do
really, really good design work.
And I don't mean product design work,
I mean how it is
that we actually co-invent together.
And one of the
enormously powerful capabilities
for innovation teams today
is the individual
and collective human being's ability
to be able to co-invent,
because as our technologies
become progressively more complex,
if we are simply working
in our own little silos,
we miss the opportunity
to do interdisciplinary work
and to do really deep innovation work.
So, I focused through working
with some of the,
really serendipitously,
working with some of the world's sort of
thought leaders when I was younger
in understanding human cognition
and human language
and how that influenced our ability
to be able to innovate and co-invent.
And I have brought that now,
through years of practice and discipline,
into the research and innovation space.
And so, I work with teams to increase
their innovation capacity.
Okay. So Jennifer,
I'm running a team, let's say.
I'm starting a company
and I have different silos
and we're working
on a variety of different projects.
What are things, as a leader,
that I can harness
in the realms of innovation?
How do I foster innovation
instead of stifle it?
Yeah. So, one of the things is
really beginning to look
at a different framework
for understanding how it is
that we manage and lead.
Traditionally, all of our management
and leadership paradigms and principles
have originated from command and control
where we are the leader
and we are supposed to be all knowing.
And those of us who've been
around long enough know
that that's a complete fallacy.
And so, it's really how do you begin
to enhance your capability
to have the brilliance of your team emerge
and that you become
a cultivator of emergence
rather than you become someone
who's telling other people what to do.
And so, I would end up working with you
to help you build yourself as that observer,
increase your capabilities in that space,
and be able to really improve the autonomy
and mastery of your team
as a result of doing ...
Right.
So, I guess the balancing question,
the complimentary question, to that is
what common pitfalls do you see
amongst leaders?
So, leaders are all around us,
whether they're C-level executives
at companies or they're tech team leaders
or they're teachers in a school
that are their own leaders in many ways.
What do you see are some common pitfalls
that people do that they're just harming
both themselves and the team?
Yeah, I think one of the saddest ones
is believing that you need to have
all the answers,
and a lot of leaders really think
that that's their role.
I think one of the fundamental differences
between leaders who amplify others
and who cultivates others
are people who are really clear
on what it is they know
and what they don't know
and who are open to continuous learning
from people all around them.
And I think if you look at some
of the more brilliant leaders today,
they will openly acknowledge
they hire people
who are smarter than them,
and they deeply listen to those people.
So, a lot of it is our belief
that we should have the answers
and then our belief that listening
is actually more about hearing
than it is really about attuning yourself
to someone else's brilliance,
which is kind of what you're doing
with this interview process, right?
You're tuning into what's unique
and brilliant about these people
I'm talking to.
Well, I'm definitely trying.
And I think that one of the fun things
that I get to do is I get to learn
really interesting things
from every person's insight.
So, you've had so many years of experience
in this field, and I have the privilege
of now sitting here and interrogating you
to find those nuggets
that could be meaningful in my journey.
But that difference
between hearing and tuning in,
talk to me about that a little.
So, what we tend to do is
we tend to communicate with each other
from the perspective
of transferring information
rather than really taking the time
to be deeply listen, be empathetic,
and really understand
what matters to other people,
what other people are passionate about,
what they care about,
and how they see and interpret the world.
And people can be trained how to do that.
And in doing that, what they do is
they begin to build the bridges
and build the opportunities
that allow them to be able to co-invent
where the capabilities
of two people or three people
or four people come together
and produce something that neither of them
could produce independently
so that the amplifying
and magnifying capability of people
learning how to build this skill set
on this competency is pretty significant.
So, as we continue on this journey
of research with innovation,
what is left to uncover do you think?
Because it sounds to me
like the way that humans are,
the way ... teamwork,
there's been so much research done
on that in the past, I guess, century.
Is there much more to innovate
when it comes to human innovation?
I think there's tons more.
So, we're doing
a super interesting project
with a client at the moment
where we're looking at
how do we really deeply understand
the decision making process
of some of the lead innovators,
what it is that they are seeing,
how they're interpreting the world,
how they're making those decisions,
how much of it is based deeply
on their experience
and how much of it is replicable
by other people.
So, we're literally building
an ontology of research innovation
and looking at how we do that.
And then one of the other areas
that I think is one
of the biggest levers today,
which is fundamentally underserved
and not understood,
is the gender balance aspect.
Right. Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
We have long neglected,
both within ourselves
and across our teams,
the ability of human beings
to be able to expand
their repertoire of understanding
and interpretation of the world
to be able to encompass all aspects
of our capability for,
at the most coarse level,
from a masculine and feminine perspective
for men and women,
but also within the individuals
where we're able to expand our repertoire
of leadership traits and qualities
and also understanding.
And I think that as we see more women
enter into the emerging tech space
and also enter into the innovation space,
we're beginning now to identify
what are some of those
leadership capabilities that are unique
and that we want to cultivate and amplify,
and then also what's the impact of those
in terms of being able
to increase innovation capability
and accelerate our innovation ambitions.
Right. And actually,
one thing that I just loved
is you corrected me right before
we started this show
because when ... started talking
about females and male leaders
and then I was talking, yes,
diversity in tech is something
that's very common.
And you said,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, Michael, it's not diversity.
It's 50 percent of the population.
This is balanced leadership."
And I just love that.
I'm adopting that,
and I'm gonna be
an advocate for that moving forward.
So, what is it about now?
What is happening in the space today?
And what do you think needs to happen
so that we have more balanced leadership
with all the positives that come with it?
Yeah, yeah. Good.
So, I think it is about balance
and not about diversity
because, again, it is half
the global population,
a little bit more than half actually,
which makes it even more interesting.
But I think what's missing in here is
we've looked at this
not as a business opportunity,
but as a social justice necessity.
And I think that is a huge fallacy
that undermined everything
that we're trying to do.
So as business leaders,
some of the more sophisticated,
advanced business leaders
with tremendous foresight are recognizing
that there is a gold mine
of opportunity there,
and if we can figure out
how to leverage that opportunity,
the leaders will obviously win,
they're the people
who are the first movers.
The difference that I have discovered
through the research that I've been doing
in terms of wasted opportunity is that
we really don't have a way
of talking about what it is
that women are doing differently
when they lead.
And there's growing awareness,
particularly with the pandemic,
because we're seeing the countries
that are led by women
have done much more successfully
in the pandemic.
Yes. Yes.
We're all asking ourselves why.
And so, I decided about 20 years ago
that I was really interested
in trying to understand
what women were doing differently
and how could you name us
how could you identify us,
how could you make it clearer
for other people
so they could understand it,
and then how could you move that
to helping people value us
and expand their repertoire of leadership.
And not just women, but women and men,
because some of the more brilliant men
that I've worked for have both male
and female leadership capabilities.
And their ability to embrace those
makes them better leaders.
And so, trying to understand
not only how that works for us
as individual human beings,
but how that works across teams,
and how we can take advantage of that
is something that I've been focused on
for a while.
And how that then impacts
our innovation capability.
And does that also translate
into your work with how women invest
as a founding LP there
and those sorts of initiatives?
Yeah. What's super interesting
with how women invest,
and I was talking to our general partner
the other day, and I said,
"Look, there's a radical difference
between the traditional venture capitalists,
who have been venture capitalists
in pursuit of capital
and distributing capital
where they think
they're gonna make higher returns,
and how women invest have built."
And what they've done is
they have produced really,
I refer to it now,
and there's growing awareness
that this is what it is,
is we're venture catalysts
because what we're doing is
we're taking money and using it
to change opportunities for people.
And not from a for benefit
or social justice perspective;
we're taking the entire
venture capital space and saying
how women invest has over
100 limited partners.
And what they're doing is that means
that there are a hundred women
who understand the venture process,
who are there to advise
and support the startups,
and who are having this catalytic effect
across the community
that they are in the middle of
which is 14,000 women across the world.
And so, the potential impact of that
from a transformation standpoint
is really huge.
So, I'm super excited about the way
my brilliant general partners
have designed their fund
and the potential long term impact
it can have across the community.
That's incredible.
But Jennifer, I have to now transition
a little bit to you and your passion
because how do you go
from being a vice president at Wells Fargo
and a senior director at Cisco
and chief information officer
and chief information and security officer
at the Stanford Research Institute,
and you go from there
to having this surge of passion
to cultivate innovation
and understand better
about balanced leadership.
What made that transition?
Why are you doing that?
So, it's not really a transition
because I've been doing that
my entire career. I've always,
So, I'm fundamentally lazy
and I always look for
what's the big lever.
And so, since the time
I was younger than you,
I went into business
and I went I need to find the big lever.
I don't want to have to work as hard
as these crazy people around me.
So, for me the biggest lever was
how do you re-frame ideas,
how do you change the way
people think about things,
and how do you bring people
with you because they want to come
not because you're telling them
that that's what they need to do.
So, my focus has always been
on how do you engage
human beings differently.
And that, to me, is the biggest lever;
if we don't understand
how to be able to mobilize resources
behind what we think is important
and find commonalities
with other humans,
we're always having to do
the heavy lifting.
And so, I've used this approach
that I learned in my early 20s
in everything that I've done,
and it's allowed me to be able to build
some incredibly powerful teams
because I'm focusing
on the emergent capabilities,
and that was actually the name
of one of my companies.
And then I've also used it
to be able to go
how do I help other people do that
so that they can build
more powerful teams around them
to be able to realize
some of the dreams and passions
that they have.
So, give me one or two tips
that I can take for myself
as I try to empower others
to want to join my team
or want to do things
because they want to,
not because they have to.
Because it sounds like
that's a key, key aspect of innovation
and part of your success
at all these wonderful companies
and corporations that you worked on.
Yeah. So, I think one of the things there
is the design element,
is people tend to follow people
who do brilliant design,
because people who do brilliant design
are looking to reduce the noise
in the system and increase the signal.
And what it does is
it creates environments where,
I, as someone who would be on your team,
can be more successful
just by virtue of the systems
that you build around you.
So, one of the little adages
I've been using
with some clients recently is,
"An hour of design is better
than 10 hours of delivery."
And so, the people who build
their design capacity, and design thinking
is obviously a fantastic tool
for doing that,
not just applied to product,
but applied to everything that we do,
is build your design capacity
and then recognize that what you're doing
in the middle of that design work
is you're providing frameworks
and constructs and opportunities for people
to be able to learn and grow
much more effectively.
Right. And is there some, the feedback loop
that you're getting from ...
I'm assuming that's
a pretty big part of it, right?
Because you could be thinking
that you're operating in a certain way
and that you're empowering people
in a certain way.
A lot of this is relationship driven.
How do you get that feedback from others?
Yeah. So, one of the fantastic things
about the design thinking work,
and systems thinking, is that
you want to be able to expose yourself
to as many feedback loops as possible.
So, when you're doing your design,
you're looking to immerse yourself
not just in feedback
that other human beings will give you,
that's super valuable,
but also in feedback
that the system itself will give you.
So, the focus on customer focused work,
the focus on customer based design work,
the focus on interdisciplinary teams
who are going to provoke your thinking
in different ways,
and how do you really create
an immersive experience for yourself
and for your teams
in the biggest, broadest ecosystem
you possibly can so that
you're doing this constant learning
and commit yourself to that.
And do it in a deliberate way.
I think a lot of people might do
immersive learning work,
but if you're not doing it
in a deliberate way
where you're looking to constantly improve
your learning capacity
and build mastery over that,
then you're missing out
on a huge opportunity.
So, I'm all about deliberate practice.
100%. 100%.
By the way, you mentioned earlier
that part of your motivation
for developing these processes and relationships is because
you saw how hard people were working
and you were trying to optimize
a lot of things.
And I think that it's pretty clear
from this conversation
that you're working much harder
than most people that I know.
So, thank you for the inspiration behind
both the optimization
but continuing to work so hard.
Jennifer, before we go, I have to ask you
the most important question
and the hardest one,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and why did you choose
those specific words.
Yeah. So, I'm a co-inventor.
I love doing things with other people.
I love seeing other people.
Co-inventor. I love that.
Co-inventor. Yeah.
It's part of what I teach people to do.
So, I love being able to invent things
with other people, and I love being able
to see the brilliance and the beauty
in other people and bring that out
and share with them
and create something bigger
than both of us or than all of us.
So, that's one
of my favorite things to do.
The other thing is
I'm a pragmatist and an executor,
because at the end of the day,
there has to be value
for vast amounts of other human beings
otherwise it's more effort
than it's worth.
And then the other thing that I do
that a number of people have said to me
that I have never really
thought of myself as
but now I'm beginning to, is I name ideas.
So, I will see people
grasping for something
that they want to make happen
in the world,
and I work with them to define that,
to distinguish that,
to translate that into
an offer our a product or service
or whatever it is,
and really name what that is
not from a marketing perspective,
but from a development
and deep understanding perspective.
And name ideas
and help them bring those ideas
to reality. So, that's ...
I love it.
Jennifer, thank you for the inspiration.
Thank you for being so generous
with your time.
I know how busy you are.
And I can't wait to share this
with the world.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Pleasure, Michael.
Take care. Bye.
Wonderful.